[Music]
even if you win today's battle there's
so much violence and what you do you
don't think I'm strong enough I don't
know if you're cruel enough powerful men
don't have to be cruel I signed up to
fight in the war I went away a soldier I
came home and Allah we do what we want
to do go where we want to go there's the
money I don't want to be a gangster stop
kissing rings a long time ago no longer
matters what you want during this life
the father says there once was a good
man in you we all find ourselves and
lives we didn't expect
repent repent repent
[Music]
this is heaven
right here we're at now I knew that
something always room you spend your
life hoping someone will punish you for
your sins to the scent was mine laughs
Here I am but you put out into this
world
what always come back to you but it
never comes back how you'll predict
is your
realize to be free in this life
breaking the rules meant nothing
you had to be strong enough to make your
own did you find out if you are a scroll
is really to be don't you always keep a
morally a better to try not there
clicked in the hotter feel well enough
that no not all that